У полі вже колоситься новий врожай, а склади ще заповнені непроданим зерном.
62-річний Дмитро Матуляк з Одеської області показує свою ферму, яка постраждала від російських обстрілів.
Згоріло понад 400 тонн корму для худоби. Чоловік із болем розповідає про жертви розв'язаної Росією війни
та ділиться труднощами виживання у непростих умовах.
Він побоюється, що український врожай гнитиме в елеваторах у той час, як багатьом людям загрожує голод.
Спостерігається зараз зворотна така тенденція: через перепони в експорті, через високі ціни на енергоносії, через простої
та інші ризики ціна на внутрішньому ринку на зернові падає на відсотків 30, а на світовому ринку зростає.
Після початку війни та блокування чорноморських портів російськими військами експорт зерна з України став фактично неможливий.
Ми називаємо порти великої Одеси. Це 7 портів навколо Одеси. Це морські ворота України, це торгівля.
І сьогодні заблоковані на території України понад 4 з половиною мільйони тонн зерна.
І це дуже серйозна проблема не лише для України, але і для тих країн, які потребують зерна і хліба.
Війна в Україні посилила і так тривожну ситуацію з глобальною продовольчою безпекою.
По всьому світу голодна смерть загрожує 49 мільйонам жителів 43 країн світу.
Щоб вирішити глобальну проблему продовольчої безпеки, треба повернути на світові ринки сільськогосподарські продукти з України,
а також продукти харчування та добрива з Росії та Білорусі, незважаючи на війну.
Ми працюємо над створенням угоди, яка дозволить Україні експортувати продукти харчування не лише залізницею,
а й Чорним морем, а також вивести російські продукти харчування та добрива на світові ринки без обмежень.
Це вимагатиме доброї волі всіх зацікавлених країн.
Влада США та генсек ООН, за даними The Wall Street Journal, розглядає варіанти тимчасового зняття санкцій з білоруських виробників добрив,
якщо офіційний Мінськ допоможе з експортом зерна з України до Євросоюзу.
Нині, коли ми говоримо про Білорусь, ми говоримо про експорт добрив, який здійснюється або з портів країн Балтії, або залізницею через Польщу.
А експорт зерна з України - це інша проблема. Я не знаю, про що саме точаться переговори.
І не можу передбачити, яким буде їхній результат. Але експорт зерна з України - це окрема тема.
Переговори з цього питання, якщо вести, то з Росією. І я не бачу зараз, щоб російське керівництво якимось чином готове було йти назустріч.
Добрива справді є одним із ключових видів товарів, які забезпечують валютний виторг. І стійкість бюджету.
Тому навіть втративши 20-30 відсотків експорту - це мільярд доларів, навіть більше. Це болісний удар.
Недивно, що білоруський правитель може використати нинішню ситуацію для того, щоб виторгувати собі санкційні послаблення, попереджають експерти.
Це ситуація такого шантажу. Людей в Україні та Білорусі ставлять перед вибором.
Або ви погоджуєтесь на зняття санкцій проти авторитарних режимів та агресорів для того, щоб врятувати людей, наприклад, в Африці від голоду.
Але не вирішується найголовніше питання: чи зможе це зупинити агресію проти України, чи зможе це припинити репресії проти білоруського народу.
Фактично ми говоримо про те, що нам пропонується зняти санкції проти агресорів замість того,
щоб змусити цих агресорів зняти блокаду з українських портів. Саме це стало би вирішенням проблеми.
Отже, не будучи здатною вирішити цю проблему, ООН, зокрема, пропонує нам таку фальшиву дилему,
щоб ми погодилися на поступки, але ці поступки будуть на користь агресорів, в першу чергу.
На посилення санкційного режиму сподівається й український фермер, який щодня стикається з наслідками російської агресії.
І не з чуток знає про зруйновані долі багатьох українців, які постраждали від цієї війни.